.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Hoffentlich
können wir bald klettern.
Profibergsteiger
Stephan Siegrist und Jonas Schild
wagen in diesem Sommer eine
Traversierung im Berner Oberland,
die so noch nie gemacht wurde.
Eine Traversierung
in brüchigem, gefährlichem Gelände.
Vom Lauterbrunnental ins Kandertal.
Elf Gipfel in drei Tagen.
45 km.
Scheisse!
Bergprofi sein
bedeutet auch immer wieder,
neue Abenteuer liefern zu müssen.
Warum tust du dir das an?
Es ist das Feuer, das noch brennt,
weil man das machen will.
Deshalb tue ich mir das an.
Wenn ich dieses Feuer nicht hätte,
wäre es mir egal.
Dies ist die Geschichte des
Profibergsteigers Stephan Siegrist,
der in über 3'000 m Höhe mit
seiner Passion sein Leben verdient.
Sein Berg: der Eiger.
Stephan Siegrist ist mit den Huber-
Brüdern aus Deutschland unterwegs
für ein internationales Filmprojekt.
Zwei Jahre mussten sie warten,
bis die Verhältnisse
in der Eigernordwand passen.
Seil, Alex! Das gelbe hängt.
Es soll ein Film über eine neue Route
in der Eigernordwand werden,
aber auch eine Tour in memoriam
abgestürzter Bergsteiger.
Und dann passiert das:
Scheisse!
Jetzt hat
einer dieser Klassikbegeher
Eisbrocken
auf mich heruntergelassen.
Es ist Zeit, runterzugehen.
Zeig mal her!
Ärgerlich war es,
weil wir gute Verhältnisse,
superstabiles Wetter hatten.
Andererseits weiss ich genau ...
... dass ich wirklich Glück hatte.
Nicht
wegen dieser Bagatelle am Kopf,
sondern vielmehr, dass es mich
durch diesen Schlag
nicht aus dem Stand geworfen hat.
Ich war im Vorstieg.
Die letzte Absicherung
12 m weiter unten -
ein kleiner Totem,
ein kleines Klemmgerät -
hätte es bei diesem Sturz
bestimmt rausgehauen.
Das hätte übel enden können.
Stef wollte zuerst weiterklettern.
Nach zwei Jahren Corona
fehlt ihm ein Projekt
mit internationaler Ausstrahlung.
Etwas weiss ich genau:
Wenn du so etwas machen willst,
musst du fit sein.
Wir drei haben
immer gegenseitige Verantwortung.
In so einem Moment würde ich mich
nicht getrauen, weiterzugehen.
Wir müssen aufpassen, dass es nicht
unser eigenes in memoriam wird.
Stef Siegrist hatte Glück,
nur seine Lippe musste genäht werden.
Er ist bald 50 Jahre alt,
Familienvater und einer der
wenigen Bergprofis in seinem Alter.
Vor über 20 Jahren begann er
seine Karriere als Profibergsteiger,
der mit spektakulären Erstbegehungen
in Patagonien
auf sich aufmerksam machte.
Er setzte neue Massstäbe
im Eis- und Mixed-Klettern.
Ihr wart schneller als wir.
International bekannt wurde er
als jüngstes Teammitglied
bei der Sendung "Eiger Live".
Und immer wieder der Eiger -
ob als Bergsteiger mit
Kletterpartnern wie Ueli Steck
oder in der Ausrüstung
der Erstbegeher.
Er erfindet sich immer wieder neu,
baut sein Image
als Abenteurer und Profi auf,
lässt sich filmisch begleiten
und kann sich medial vermarkten.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Inzwischen kann er gut von
seinen Bergsteigerprojekten leben.
So hat er sich während der Coronazeit
ein eigenes Studio eingerichtet,
da Vorträge über seine Expeditionen
rund 50 %
seines Einkommens ausmachen.
Daneben ist er
immer noch als Bergführer unterwegs
und hat im Winter einen Gast,
der ihn exklusiv bucht.
Das Wichtigste aber
sind die Sponsoren,
die ihn für seine Abenteuer bezahlen.
Das darf man nicht schönreden.
Der Druck ist ganz klar da.
Es ist aber nicht so, dass die
Sponsoren das so aussprechen.
Aber es ist in jedem Sport so,
wenn man drei, vier Jahre keinen
Erfolg hat, wird man uninteressant.
Dadurch entsteht eine
gewisse Abhängigkeit von Erfolgen.
Deshalb plant Stef als Vorbereitung
auf eine grosse Expedition im Herbst
eine Tour in den Schweizer Alpen -
gemeinsam mit dem jungen Bergprofi
Jonas Schild.
So, wie es tönt, ist es eine
steil abfallende, mühsame Rinne,
die zu traversieren ist.
Eigentlich ist es einfacher,
wenn du von unten her kommst.
Um die Erfolgschancen zu erhöhen,
fassen sie zwei Projekte ins Auge.
Man kann sich überlegen, mal ein
Stück weit von unten her zu gehen.
Ich denke, in dieser Wand
kann man überall biwakieren.
Eines
ist die Wand des Bietschorns/VS,
das andere ist die Grattraversierung
im Berner Oberland.
Wenn in dieser Rinne
loses Gerümpel ist ...
In der Nacht gehst du irgendwo rein.
Hier hört der Schatten auf.
Je nach Wetter- und
Schneeverhältnissen
können sie spontan entscheiden.
Beide Touren sind Erstbegehungen.
Für das Gspaltenhorn werden wir
so wenig wie möglich mitnehmen.
Aber ich denke, ein paar Totems
nehmen wir sicher mit.
Auf das Bietschhorn würde ich
sicher etwa sechs oder sieben
Expressen mitnehmen.
Oder sogar mehr.
Warten, bis die Verhältnisse passen,
planen, vorbereiten.
Drei Wochen lang haben sie in
ihrem Terminkalender alles blockiert.
Im Moment
herrscht eine leichte Nervosität.
Es ist wieder das Wetter.
In den Tagen,
die wir vorgesehen haben,
sieht es aus,
als wäre es etwas instabil.
Das macht einen schon etwas nervös.
Aber wir finden eine Lösung.
Wir haben ein langes Zeitfenster.
Wir nehmen es zusammen, oder?
- Schön zusammengefaltet.
* Lachen *
Die Tour dient Stef und Jonas
als Vorbereitung
für eine Expedition am Shivling,
den sie schon letztes Jahr
besteigen wollten.
Hier sieht man ...
Der Berg befindet sich in Indien.
Es ist
ein ästhetisch sehr schöner Berg.
Er hat eine Südwand,
die so noch nicht begangen ist.
An diesem Projekt
waren wir bereits letztes Jahr dran.
Wir mussten aber abbrechen, weil
jemand ein Höhenlungenödem hatte.
Das ist im unteren Teil dieser Wand.
Wie man sieht, gab es
am Tag zuvor etwas Niederschlag.
* Husten *
Heute Morgen hätten wir
eigentlich einsteigen wollen,
um die Pfeiler zu fixieren.
Aber jetzt ist es
komplett eingezuckert.
* Husten *
Ein Riesenscheissdreck.
"Scheissdreck."
* Lachen *
Bis jetzt durftet ihr über diese
Expedition nichts veröffentlichen.
Richtig, ja.
Eigentlich gar nichts.
Nicht einmal auf Social Media
durfte man
etwas zum Projekt erzählen.
Exklusivbilder, die bisher
nicht gezeigt werden durften.
Es ist ein Filmprojekt,
das von Red Bull unterstützt wird,
da neben Stef und Jonas der Red-Bull-
Athlet Nicolas Hojac dabei ist.
Sie mussten die Auflage eingehen,
dass die Bilder
erst veröffentlicht werden dürfen,
wenn sie die Besteigung
ein zweites Mal versucht haben,
denn ein reiner Misserfolg
ohne einen zweiten Versuch
wäre für den Partner Red Bull
uninteressant.
Wie stark geben euch Sponsoren
Vorgaben?
Wir sind total frei
in den Projekten.
Natürlich ist es so, dass sie sagen,
sie würden uns unterstützen.
wenn sie das Gefühl haben,
es marketingtechnisch
verwenden zu können.
Dort ist es wichtig, dass man sich
nicht beeinflussen lässt
und seinen Weg geht.
Einmal helfen sie finanziell,
d.h., mit Firmen mitschicken,
und ein anderes Mal halt nicht.
Zusammen mit dem Eiger
sind es nun zwei Grossprojekte,
die nicht zustande kamen.
Was bedeutet das für dich
in deiner Situation?
Es ist verdammt mühsam.
Man hat in alle diese Projekte
viel Zeit investiert
und hat keinen Output.
Das ärgert einen natürlich.
Das ist so. Das ist nicht gut.
Wie gehst du damit um?
In all den Jahren habe ich gelernt,
dass Misserfolg dazugehört.
Wenn es aber
ein Misserfolg nach dem anderen ist,
gleichzeitig kommt Corona,
ist wie ein Loch dazwischen,
in dem du nichts hast.
Schlussendlich ...
... ernähre ich auch eine Familie.
Ich kann die Familie ernähren,
wenn ich auch Vorträge halten kann.
Die letzte erfolgreiche Expedition
war Patagonien im Dezember 2019.
Zum Glück gingen wir noch,
bevor alles geschlossen wurde.
Aber in einem Vortrag kannst du
ja nicht nur vom Abseilen erzählen.
Mit Jonas Schild ist er
bereits seit sechs Jahren unterwegs.
Es ist schwül.
Stef Siegrist
plant seine Expeditionen
inzwischen bewusst
mit jungen Profibergsteigern.
Es wird noch regnen.
Es hat ganz klar auch damit zu tun,
dass viele meiner Kollegen
das gar nicht mehr machen.
Also gleichaltrige Kollegen,
mit denen ich oft unterwegs war.
Es mangelt mir
ein bisschen an Leuten.
Aber für mich ist es
natürlich ein ganz grosses Plus,
wenn ich
mit den Jungen mitgehen darf.
Ich kann eigentlich nicht klettern,
ich kann mich
einfach sehr gut strecken.
Alles gut bei dir?
- Ja.
Jonas gehört mit 30 Jahren
zu den absoluten Topbergsteigern,
gerade in technischen Kletterrouten.
Ich kann von Jonas profitieren,
indem ...
Wenn es in einer grossen Wand
eine schwierige Seillänge gibt,
ist ganz klar,
dass er schneller vorwärtskommt.
Wir müssen uns vorher einhängen,
er macht es frei.
Insbesondere, wenn es Risse sind,
wie es sie im Hochgebirge oft hat.
Da ist er sehr stark.
Stef hat nicht mehr so viel Zeit,
um in der Wand zu trainieren.
Ein grosser Teil
ist die gegenseitige Ergänzung.
Wie er sagte, bin ich
technisch ein bisschen stärker.
Er hat aber massiv mehr Erfahrung.
Dort kann ich sehr viel lernen.
Es ist nicht unbedingt
die Erfahrung
im Sinne von
sehr klassisch unterwegs sein.
Aufgefallen ist mir
das sehr Strategische.
Die Entscheide im Vorfeld.
In diesem Punkt
profitiere ich sehr von Stef.
Stef ist Vater von zwei Söhnen.
Am Dienstag ist er fix zu Hause,
da seine Frau Niki
als Lehrerin arbeitet.
Ich schaue mal.
Ein Spezialzimmer
kostet 5 Fr. mehr pro Person.
Inzwischen sieht es danach aus,
als ob das Wetter passt
und die Tour gestartet werden kann.
Geplant ist die Traversierung
im Berner Oberland.
Wenn ich es buchen kann,
erhältst du ein Bestätigungsmail.
Tipptopp.
- Bis bald.
Bis bald. Danke! Einen schönen Tag.
- Merci! Tschau, Stephan!
Stef organisiert die Übernachtung
in der Gspaltenhornhütte
und bereitet das Essen
für seinen jüngsten Sohn,
den 11-jährigen Xavier, vor.
Hoi! Wie geht es?
- Gut. Und dir?
Gut gelaufen?
- Mhm.
War es streng?
Ja? Lief der Mathetest gut?
- Ja, sehr.
Wirklich?
Zum Glück haben wir geübt.
- Ja.
Stef, wie egoistisch ist es,
dass du das durchziehst?
Hä! Ja, wie egoistisch?
Ja ...
Ich denke, jeder, der in seinem
Berufsleben ein grösseres Ziel hat,
bringt einen gewissen Egoismus mit.
Bei mir kommt noch die Passion dazu.
Das macht es nicht einfacher.
Aber dank den Kindern
durfte ich auch lernen,
dass man auch zurückstehen muss.
Wenn man
andere im ähnlichen Alter sieht ...
... die diese schöne
Familienverpflichtung nicht haben,
dafür aber viel mehr Zeit haben
und mehr Projekte machen,
muss man am Ende doch sagen:
"Ich habe es eigentlich super."
Viele Kollegen in seinem Alter
haben wegen der Familie
aufgehört zu klettern.
Bist du zufrieden
mit Papa als Hausmann?
Ja.
Mama macht auch viel.
- Mama macht viel mehr.
Was?
Aber du hilfst ihr.
An Niki
bleibt ganz klar viel hängen.
Die ganze Organisation, die Kinder.
Da habe ich nicht sehr viel zu tun.
Käse fehlt noch.
- Ja.
Stand die Frage im Raum,
mit Spitzenklettern aufzuhören?
Wurdest du vor diese Frage gestellt?
Nein, weder von der Partnerin
noch von der Familie.
Diese Frage musste ich mir
persönlich selber stellen.
Aber wenn ich unseren eigentlich
sehr guten Lebensstil anschaue
und ich gleichzeitig
meine Passion weiterleben darf,
was mir natürlich
sehr viel Freude bereitet ...
... ist es tatsächlich ein Privileg.
Hätte ich
vor zehn Jahren entschieden,
in einem Büro zu arbeiten,
wäre ich nicht derselbe.
Ich wäre nicht glücklich.
Wenden!
- Ich fahre weg.
Profiklettern
ist eine Passion mit Risiko.
Es ist eine traurige Tatsache,
dass viele seiner Kollegen
in seinem Alter nicht mehr leben,
weil sie tragisch verunfallt sind.
Xavier,
hattest du schon Angst um ihn?
Nicht wirklich, weil ich weiss, dass
er keine grossen Gefahren eingeht,
z.B. den Everest besteigt,
der ja sehr hoch ist.
Manchmal
habe ich schon ein bisschen Angst.
Aber ich weiss, dass ihm nichts
wirklich Schlimmes passieren kann.
Was machst du, wenn du Angst hast?
Warten, bis die Nachricht kommt,
dass alles gut ist.
Ich warte einfach ab.
Jetzt hast du das Segel aufgemacht,
nicht?
So halb.
Ich habe es auf Position B.
Okay.
Auch Stef hatte
immer wieder Verletzungen,
Unfälle,
die tödlich hätten enden können,
so wie an der Eigernordwand.
Du hast Kollegen verloren
in der Eigernordwand,
die in ähnlichen Situationen waren.
Ja, das ist richtig. Auch dort ...
Das ging mir
natürlich auch lange durch den Kopf.
Auch dort
ist es am Schluss Schicksal.
Julian, ein sehr guter Freund,
hätte sich bei diesem Sturz
auch nur den Arm brechen können.
Was ist dort passiert?
Man weiss, dass er sich
bei diesem Sturz das Genick brach.
So kam er ums Leben.
Das hätte dir auch passieren können.
- Ja.
Es ist nur ein Strick.
Wir haben einen David Lama,
der jünger war.
Du bist einer derjenigen,
die überlebt haben.
Was geht dir da durch den Kopf?
Zum Glück bin ich nicht der Einzige.
Es gibt Ältere,
die auch überlebt haben.
Schlussendlich
ist es immer auch Schicksal.
Heute bin ich so weit,
dass ich sage,
dass alle irgendwo ihr Lichtlein,
ihr Kerzlein haben.
Wenn das auslöschen muss,
löscht es aus.
Da kannst du
noch so viel dafür oder dagegen tun.
Viel kannst du wohl nicht machen.
D.h. aber nicht, dass man
kopflos unterwegs sein soll.
Ist es nicht auch ein Verdrängen?
Ich denke ...
Am Berg musst du es verdrängen,
sonst bist du am falschen Ort.
Wenn das am Berg präsent ist ...
... behindert dich das
sowohl im Weiterklettern
als auch im klaren Denken.
Dort darfst du nicht
an einen Unfall denken.
Dort musst du dich fokussieren,
auf das, was du machst.
Das musst du möglichst gut
und möglichst sicher machen.
Was sagst du Niki,
wenn sie sich Sorgen machen würde?
Das ist ein anderer Punkt.
Hätte Niki schlaflose Nächte,
wenn ich unterwegs bin ...
... könnte ich wohl
nicht mehr Bergsteigen gehen.
Ich hätte ein schlechtes Gewissen,
wenn ich draussen wäre ...
... meiner Passion nachginge
und jemand zu Hause
sehr darunter leiden würde.
Zwei Tage später geht es los.
Niki und Stef
sind seit 15 Jahren zusammen.
Sie ist gebürtige Kanadierin.
Auch sie
hat einen Hang zum Abenteuer.
Kennengelernt haben sie sich
beim Fallschirmspringen.
Auf der einen Seite
ist es eine Erleichterung,
wenn es bei Stef losgeht.
Und da ist immer die Hoffnung,
dass es klappt.
Es ist v.a. viel ruhiger,
wenn er einmal unterwegs ist.
Die Ruhe nach dem Sturm. Der Sturm
ist meistens, bevor er geht.
Viel Glück
beim Schwimmwettkampf am Samstag.
Merci.
Mach's gut!
- Merci.
Bis am Sonntag.
Mach's gut!
I try to call you.
- Yes, let me know.
Tschüss!
- Tschau!
Er verpasst natürlich,
was wir machen in dieser Zeit.
Bis er zurückkommt,
ist diese Zeit ein Loch.
Wir wissen auch noch nicht,
was er macht.
So ...
What you guys doing
this afternoon at school?
BG.
Oh!
Vom Lauterbrunnental ins Kandertal:
Elf Gipfel in drei Tagen,
5'400 Höhenmeter in Gelände,
das teilweise
noch nie so begangen wurde.
Die Herausforderung ist schon,
die Konzentration zu behalten,
weil es viel loses Zeug hat.
Da könntest du schnell mal
mit einer Steinplatte abwärtsgehen.
Das ist bis jetzt
die Hauptschwierigkeit.
Neben der Wegfindung.
Aber das ging eigentlich gut.
I love it!
Zudem liegt die Nullgradgrenze
in diesen Tagen auf über 4'500 m.
Jetzt geht es hier über den Pfeiler
und dann links hinauf
über diese Verschneidung.
Schauen wir mal!
- Ja.
Wir nehmen das Seil.
Ihr Ziel heute
ist die Traverse über sechs Gipfel
zum Gspaltenhorn auf 3'446 m.
Ein stetes Auf und Ab über einen Grat
gespickt mit Türmen
voll steilem, brüchigem Fels.
Geht es?
Schwierigkeit: Was wir
bis jetzt gemacht haben, ist S+.
Ja.
- D.h., schön plus.
Was jetzt kommt, ist nur noch schön.
Zum Glück heisst es nicht ZS,
ziemlich schön.
Und AS ist dann abnormal schön.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt
auf das Gspaltenhorn ...
... auf den sagenumwobenen Ostgrat.
* Dynamische Rockmusik *
Dachdecker sollte man sein.
Im Moment muss man nehmen,
was kommt.
Man kann
nicht allzu wählerisch sein.
Nach über 10 Std.
erreichen sie die Schlüsselpassage:
den Ostgrat des Gspaltenhorns.
Vor sich zwei riesige Türme.
Warte noch rasch!
Hier müssen sie abseilen
und die Türme
durch eine brüchige Rinne umgehen.
Danach gibt es
keinen Weg mehr zurück.
Stef, ist aus?
Jawohl, es kommt gut.
Was wir sicher nicht machen,
ist durchs Wasser hoch.
Das Wasser ist das eine,
aber da kommen auch Steine mit.
Unliebsame Überraschung -
statt Fels nur Geröll.
Die spärlichen Informationen, die sie
aus der Führerliteratur hatten,
stimmen heute nicht mehr.
Sie sitzen fest
und mit ihnen auch das Kamerateam.
Das wird nichts mit dem Seil.
- Nein.
Stef, wie sieht es dort aus?
Wir müssen
auf jeden Fall hier hinauf.
Das ist klar. Aber von hier
sieht man nicht, wie weiter.
Wir sind
am Ostgrat des Gspaltenhorns.
Südlich dieser zwei Türme.
Wir müssen schauen,
wie es weitergeht.
Eigentlich sollten wir
südlich in diese hässliche Rinne.
Wir sehen nicht gut,
wie man da reinkommt.
Es sieht relativ nass aus,
weil es noch Schnee drin hat.
Aber vielleicht
ist es drinnen dann trocken.
Stef ist am Schauen.
So sieht es aus.
Aus die Maus.
Stef, wie sieht es aus?
Hä?
- Wie sieht es aus?
Ich sehe nichts.
Eine riesige Scheisse.
Du gibst acht, gell?
- Ja.
Sieht es gut aus?
Ich brauche ein Seil.
So komme ich nicht rein.
Das Zeug fällt natürlich hier rein.
Ich muss zuerst mit einem Seil rein.
Rechts könnte man aber hinauf.
Ja, der Fels sieht besser aus,
aber einfach ist es bestimmt nicht.
Es ist steil. Aber es wäre
allenfalls eine Variante.
Kann dich der Heli hier holen?
Nach einer Stunde
entscheiden sie sich,
doch über die Nordseite der Türme
auszusteigen.
Ihre einzige Chance,
eine Passage, so brüchig, dass sie
bisher noch niemand gewagt hat.
Doch sie schaffen es.
Nach 12 Std.
stehen sie auf dem Gspaltenhorn.
Gratuliere!
- Bravo! Super!
Das war spannend.
* Sanfte Musik *
Den ganzen Tag
ein bisschen wie auf Eiern.
Ein bisschen angespannt.
Zum Glück fanden wir einen Ausweg,
sonst würden wir dort unten sitzen.
* Lachen *
Also, gehen wir!
Sieben Gipfel
haben sie an diesem Tag bestiegen.
Nach 14 Std. klettern, kommen sie
in der Gspaltenhornhütte an.
Gratulation zu eurer Leistung.
- Danke!
Gesundheit!
Wie wir gemerkt haben,
ist nicht alles fest.
* Lachen *
Es sind schon überall
Leute durchgegangen.
Aber wahrscheinlich hat diese
Überquerung so noch niemand gemacht.
Also vom Spitzhorn
wirklich bis aufs Gspaltenhorn.
Ich werde sie
bestimmt nicht noch einmal machen.
Ist es auch heikel?
Ja, es war schon heikel.
Man hat halt null Marge.
Du darfst dir
keinen Fehler erlauben.
Jeden Griff, den du in die Hand
nimmst, musst du testen.
Jeden Tritt musst du testen.
Zum Glück
können wir uns absolut vertrauen,
sonst würdest du nicht weit kommen.
Das braucht es.
Mit einem, zu dem du
dieses Vertrauen nicht hast,
gehst du mental kaputt.
Wenn du immer Angst hast,
er reisse dich irgendwo hinunter.
* Sanfte Musik *
Morgen gehen wir ähnlich wie heute.
Wir stehen um 2.20 Uhr auf.
Danach gehen wir gleich.
Es ist ein bisschen schade, dass die
Temperaturen morgen noch höher sind.
D.h., dass wir
bei der Blüemlisalp-Überquerung
das eine oder andere Problem
haben könnten.
* Sanfte Musik *
Wegen der hohen Temperaturen sind sie
bereits um 2.30 Uhr gestartet.
Ihr erstes Ziel:
das Morgenhorn über die Südwandrippe.
Kurz vor 9 Uhr
stehen sie auf dem Morgenhorn.
Diese Südwandrippe ist sehr schön.
Eigentlich eine versteckte Perle.
Im Vergleich zu gestern super Fels.
Jetzt nervt mich der Wind.
Aber er hat auch ...
- ... sein Gutes.
Sonst wäre es warm.
Dank des Windes erreichen sie
die Blüemlisalp auf 3'661 m
in kompaktem Schnee -
trotz bereits hoher Temperaturen.
Maestro.
- Selber.
Sehr geil.
- Alles gut.
Hallo zusammen!
Doch der gestrige Tag
hat Spuren hinterlassen.
Ich könnte mich
hier gleich hinlegen und schlafen.
Bist du noch ein bisschen kaputt
von gestern? Das hat angehängt.
Ja, das würde ich so auch sagen.
Das mit der Sehne ist scheisse.
Das habe ich fast jedes Jahr
zu Beginn des Jahres.
Vom Steigeisen oder vom hoch Treten
entzündet sich der Muskelansatz.
Meistens habe ich aber nach einem
anstrengenden Tag wieder etwas Ruhe.
Jetzt kumuliert es sich
natürlich ein bisschen.
Auf dem Handy suchen sie
den weiteren Weg
Richtung Fründenhorn.
Jetzt noch das mit dem Abstieg.
Hast du gesehen?
Es ist bereits am Rutschen.
Rund 3'000 m weiter unten
ist Niki mit Xavier
am Schwimmwettkampf in Spiez.
(Speakerin) Zweiter Platz:
Xavier Siegrist aus Interlaken.
Xavier wird Zweiter
in seiner Altersklasse.
(Speakerin) Auf dem ersten Platz
ist Geidel Henri aus Interlaken.
* Jubel und Applaus *
Wieder ein Anlass,
bei dem Stef fehlt.
Another normal saturday.
Alles da.
Stef und Jonas versinken derweil
im Schnee im Aufstieg zum Oeschihorn.
Das ist grosse Scheisse.
Ich frage mich, wie wir heute
noch über einen Gletscher wollen.
Oh, ist das heiss!
- Ein Bad im See wäre schön.
Dass Stef immer wieder
in den Bergen unterwegs ist,
gehört zum Leben von Niki.
Ob ich mir manchmal Sorgen mache?
Ja, um alle, natürlich auch um Stef.
Aber die Angst ist nicht so,
dass ich ihn stoppen möchte,
das zu tun, was er macht.
Oder, dass es mich
nicht schlafen lässt.
Mir ist bewusst, dass ein Risiko
da ist, wie in anderen Berufen auch.
Aber der Gewinn daraus
ist viel grösser,
als das Risiko dahinter.
Für uns wäre es beunruhigender,
nicht in dieser Situation zu sein.
Das ist unsere Komfortzone,
unser Leben.
Geht das, um hinunterzuklettern?
Stef und Jonas erreichen
eine weitere Schlüsselstelle.
Den Abstieg über den äusserst
brüchigen Westgrat zum Fründenhorn.
Sie haben zu wenig Seil
und Schlaghaken dabei,
um weitere Abseilstellen zu bauen
und sicher
über den Gletscher zu kommen.
Wir sind noch nirgends.
Was mir nicht gefällt, ist,
dass bei dieser Wärme,
dieser Sonneneinstrahlung,
der gesamte Mist runterkommt.
Das ist schwierig zu sagen.
Finde ich.
Ich wollte es nur sagen.
Ich denke, nun ist der letzte
Moment, wo man noch gut zurückkommt.
Wie spät ist es?
- 13 Uhr.
Wenn wir dort gehen, gehen wir
sicher nicht mehr aufs Fründenhorn.
Joni, siehst du das auch so?
- Ja.
Ich sehe es auch so.
Jetzt können wir
die Handbremse noch ziehen.
Weiter unten sind wir im Scheiss.
- Ja, stimmt.
Also, komm!
- Ich komme wieder hinauf.
Das würde ich auch sagen.
Dann gehen wir
diesen Schrott wieder hoch.
Sie steigen wieder auf
zum Oeschihorn.
Thanks a lot.
Der Entscheid ist gefällt.
Wir haben es gestern
genügend ausgereizt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist nicht vernünftig.
Manchmal musst du es versuchen,
dann aber auch
den richtigen Entscheid treffen.
Ob er richtig ist,
wissen wir noch nicht,
aber wir haben einen getroffen.
Es war sicher der bessere.
Das gehört dazu.
Das ist Teil des Bergsteigens.
So erreichen sie auf der Normalroute
nach einem weiteren 14-Std.-Tag
die Fründenhütte.
Schlussendlich haben wir
diesen einen Gipfel nicht gemacht.
Aber ich glaube, in der Situation,
in der wir heute Nachmittag
auf diesem Grat waren,
war es eigentlich schon
die ziemlich richtige Entscheidung.
Es macht keinen Sinn,
ein grosses Risiko einzugehen ...
... nur um noch
einen Gipfel mehr zu machen.
Als letzter Gipfel
fehlt morgen noch das Doldenhorn.
Zusätzlich zu den hohen Temperaturen
ist ein Gewitter angesagt.
Diesen Punkt
müssen wir im Hinterkopf haben.
Es könnte dazu führen,
dass es morgen nicht klappt.
Man muss auch beachten, dass wir
auch schon ein bisschen müde sind.
Dann braucht es nicht viel.
Man versteigt sich oder sonst etwas.
Wenn dann
ein Gewitter kommen würde ...
... wären wir sicher
am falschen Ort.
Dann wäre es nicht schlau gewesen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Aus Sicherheitsgründen entscheiden
sie sich für den Galletgrat
und erreichen so
sicher das Doldenhorn,
ihren letzten Gipfel dieser Tour.
Uh! Hammer!
Geil!
- Merci vielmal!
Gipfel Nummer 11 - glaube ich.
Auf jeden Fall der letzte.
* Lachen *
Für heute und morgen.
Schon krass,
was man mit den Beinen machen kann.
Vielleicht ist es das, was
den bald 50-jährigen Stef Siegrist
weiterklettern lässt -
diese Mischung aus Abenteuer
und der Erfahrung,
nicht mehr alles riskieren zu müssen.
Ich würde das gerne
noch ein paar Jahre machen.
Das ist meine Leidenschaft,
das mache ich gerne.
Ich habe noch viele Ideen im Kopf,
die ich noch verwirklichen möchte.
Ob ich Angst habe, aufzuhören?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Ich mache mir keine grossen Gedanken
bzw. ich habe keine grossen Ängste,
dass es nicht irgendwie weitergeht.
Finanzielle Ängste hatte ich nie.
Ich hatte immer das Gefühl,
dass wieder etwas kommt.
Bis jetzt hat es so funktioniert.